[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
observers chief leader writer sonia soda
and the spectator's deputy political
editor katie balls they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages the metro describes as true
courage the actions of afghan women
protesting in the streets against the
reimposed rule of the taliban
the financial times leads with the
taliban's assertion that they will
respect women's rights as they put it
within islam's framework
the express reports that the home office
intends to allow 20 000 afghan refugees
to settle in britain that's also the top
story for the guardian
picturing two afghan children the mirror
urges the uk government to save them
while the telegraph carries an article
by the home secretary priti patel in
which she urges the uk's european
neighbours to take in refugees as well
and the daily star reports on the
closure of some nando's restaurants due
to staff shortages and trouble with
their supply chain
and tonight we're joined by sonia soda
and katie balls good evening to you both
we're going to kick off with the
financial times and and it is looking at
one of the central themes of that
extraordinary news conference sonia that
we had from the taliban in the
presidential palace
today
what will happen to the rights of women
and girls within afghanistan now
yes that's right and in the press
conference today we saw the taliban
saying that it would be different this
time that they will respect women's
rights within the framework of islam but
i think those guarantees mean very
little to women and girls in afghanistan
first of all there's a taliban's track
record absolutely abhorrent um human
rights abuses against women in
afghanistan when they ruled afghanistan
in the past when it comes to things like
stoning for committing adultery
amputation of limbs of of women who um
they say are guilty of stealing for
example and you know there was a very
important qualifier around what they
were saying today which you know they
were saying that they would respect
women's rights rights within the the
framework of sharia law and and we know
what the taliban's interpretation of
sharia law is because we've seen it in
the past and we've also seen um in
recent weeks and months
when they've taken over provincial
capitals in afghanistan what that has
mean for um women who live in those
areas and we've had reports of women
being um targeted in the most awful of
ways um you know uh underage girls uh
being forced to marry uh fighters uh and
being raped by them so um i think these
these promises and and pledges i mean
they are probably an attempt by the
taliban to sort of um sound uh moderate
but i don't think they will be very
reassuring to uh people in afghanistan
and katie that the photograph that the
ft have chosen on their front page and i
think we've got some moving footage of
it or are afghan women
in kabul
demanding the protection of their rights
extraordinary act of bravery in the face
of members of the taliban right in front
of them
yes completely and it's one of those
things where you're seeing women women
going out and trying to say well this is
my right to protest but as you say it's
a very brave act because we are in
territory no one is quite sure what's
going to happen
and i think that you can see that in the
sense that uh
although the taliban are talking as
though they have found a new respect for
women's rights and if you believe it and
particularly when these uh you know
cameras go away what's going to happen
there and what's going to happen to
these women so it's a very brave thing
to do and i think lots of actually quite
worried for these people in a way for
doing it and because of the situation
they are now in
casey let's have a look at the front
page of the guardian and that is the
news that's broken in the last few
minutes that the uk is to take 20 000
refugees fleeing the taliban at 20 000
in total five thousand in the first year
yes and this is on top of a prize scheme
for five thousand um and
this comes after boris johnson has been
under a lot of pressure i think from
both sides of the house many mps within
his own party some of his ministers um
to really set out what the uk plans to
do um they've been devastating scenes
from afghanistan if you think about the
past few days and i think that
everyone agrees that the uk has a moral
duty to these people
i think in terms of the scheme it's
based uh similarly on the syrian refugee
scheme which is also around twenty
thousand um and it's meant to focus on
women and girls and those who have most
need i think there's still some
questions on this so number one the
speed the fact that it's five thousand
initially and two i think the passage
the journey and how how you get there
because we've seen these um horrifying
uh you know pictures of people clinging
to planes and we know that part of the
problem right now is actually getting
out in the first place and again while
the taliban are talking rather you know
nicely no one is quite sure what happens
once you have a situation where uh you
know the u.s are no longer in charge of
that airport so i think there are lots
of things to press the details on when
mps meet tomorrow for the recall of
parliament to to debate these measures
yeah and sonia the the uk commander in
charge of uh the evacuations from the uk
side there in kabul admitting today that
they don't know how long they'll be
allowed to operate there for i mean it
is a race against time to get people
back we are waiting for the next flight
to come in
to bryce norton tonight but what do you
make on the announcement of this
resettlement scheme for 20 000.
well i think the first thing to say is
that any resettlement scheme is
obviously better than no resettlement
scheme so that in and of itself is good
news but i agree with katie that there
are serious questions to be asked first
of all looking back at the government's
record we've had people urging for
months and weeks that the government was
not doing enough to bring over people at
risk who've worked with the british
government who were really seriously at
risk from the taliban advance in
afghanistan and even you know three four
weeks ago we had ex-military chiefs
writing to the government saying they
urgently needed to reconsider this
because there are people who have worked
with the british government perhaps not
directly employed but who've been having
asylum applications under this scheme
being turned down
and the government just didn't do enough
on that it didn't act urgently enough
then there are these questions about you
know fine it's good to have these roots
but it's coming so late that actually
how are people going to get out and then
i think there's a question to be asked
about the scale of the scheme as well
and alf dobbs raises these questions in
that guardian article five thousand in
one year doesn't feel like many
when you consider britain's involvement
in afghanistan um over the years and you
know the fact that actually we take far
fewer um asylum seekers and um refugees
than many other european countries we're
17th down the list in europe when you
look at the number of refugees we take
per population head so
is this really britain doing its bit
it's a start but i think that we should
have been doing more in the run-up to
this which everyone was predicting
perhaps not so fast and i think 5000 in
one year will leave people asking a lot
of questions about whether it's enough
in the here and now
we've got two very different takes on
this in the express and the mirror if we
have a look at the express first big
hearted at britain to take 20 000
refugees the headline there women and
girls being given priority being modeled
on the the syrian vulnerable persons
resettlement scheme widely viewed as a
success katie and the mirror
then has a photograph of
two siblings seeking refuge in kabul
saying save them uh the mirrors approach
to this is 5000 this year it just isn't
enough
yes and ultimately suggesting the
government needs to go further and i
think that would be a fairly popular
view when please meet in the house of
commons tomorrow uh speaking to tory mps
today lots were saying well at minimum
we should uh have thirty thousand some
are saying figures much higher so do you
think there'll be pressure on that but
there's obviously questions about how
realistic is how practical is to get
schemes like this going
but i do you got that headline figure
but the fact is only 5 000 in the first
year i think is going to get a lot of
attention i think as sonia touched on
the thing we really can't escape here is
ultimately the government has been
caught on the heart it's been caught by
surprise at how fast things moved in
afghanistan
and that means that the preparations
have not been in place i think there are
serious questions to answer on that
particularly when you think about um the
various uh you know there's lots of
stories today uh interpreters who had
their applications paused just slowed
down by the home office um now in really
very vulnerable and dangerous situations
um hiding out and i think it's a
question as to really how fast this can
move um and i think as the defense
secretary ben wallace ultimately said an
interview this week not everyone is
going to be able to get here and i think
that is what can't really be escaped
despite obviously progress with this
scheme
yes certainly plenty of questions for
the prime minister when parliament's
recalled tomorrow uh sonia he's been
speaking to president biden this evening
and a g7 meeting to be convened
yeah that's right and president biden
has come in for a huge amount of
criticism over the last kind of 48 hours
both domestically in the us but also
internationally i think and i think you
know obviously boris johnson's words to
president joe biden that have been
released they're very diplomatic um
they're very polite as you would expect
but i think behind the scenes there's a
lot of anger amongst um you know british
diplomats at not just the direction that
u.s policy was heading in because i
think you know even when um
biden was obama's vice president it was
quite clear what he thought about the
u.s president at the u.s presence in
afghanistan but i think what's just
really shocked international observers
actually is that the reckless way in
which the us has just drawn out um in
order to meet some arbitrary deadline um
in a way that actually some experts were
warning that this would lead to a
collapse of the afghan army because of
the the complete loss of morale that
that would generate amongst afghan
troops um the reliance on a small number
of american troops for their expertise
on aircraft power for example so i think
this is going to really
hurt joe biden um in the medium turn and
i think it might end up we might end up
looking on this as something that harms
the us and indeed the worst strategic
interests not just the people of
afghanistan and actually um you know
it's being reported tonight that biden's
um
ratings are the lowest that they've ever
been they've fallen seven points and i
think that that's probably not something
that his officials and his advisers
would have been expecting yeah joe biden
of course defiant in that news
conference last night that this was a
binary choice between a forever war or
getting out let's take a short break
katie and sonia back with us in just a
couple of minutes and we will be
discussing the kovid jab which has been
approved for use on children as young as
12 do stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me sonia soda and katie
balls we're going to turn to the front
of the telegraph now and it has a story
about the snp
and concerns being expressed about plans
to retain pandemic powers sonia what
powers are we talking about
so these are some of the extraordinary
powers um that uh would give that
westminster sort of turk and the
scottish uh were given to the scottish
government in the case of a pandemic so
um you know the power is for example to
impose lockdown to close schools uh to
require people to wear face coverings in
public so really this is a political row
that's brewing uh because the scottish
government feels that these are powers
that should reside with the scottish
government for in case of future
pandemics uh whereas the westminster
government is saying these are
extraordinary powers um we you know
we're going to take them back
and it was just for this pandemic and so
i think this is based essentially around
about political wow about devolution and
where these powers should sit in the
long term because i think there's no
question that if there's a pandemic
again we will need to see these sort of
measures if it's a similar sort of
pandemic it's just about who's got the
power to enforce them katie
and i think it's interesting because it
hints at i think what some government's
now grappling with which is are we
changing how we govern uh after a health
crisis this uh in anticipation of future
ones or is this a power grab and i do
think here you can see how it'd be
useful to the government particularly
things so uncertain if you look at the
israel israeli government at the moment
thinking about this fourth wave of
covert to move quickly and move fast but
then i also think that if these measures
aren't really as popular as smp are
claiming um it shouldn't be a problem
getting support to bring them back in
remove them as and when anyway and we do
have to be a bit wary i think of uh
giving the state uh powers that then are
almost about scrutiny to a degree
uh sonny let's have a look at the metro
staying with covid and the moderna jab
which has been
authorised for 12 to 17 year olds today
yes that's right so the health regulator
has um authorized a second vaccine as
safe for 12 to 17 year olds that's a
moderna vaccine alongside the fighter
vaccine
now this is significant because it means
16 and 17 year olds will be able to get
modern vaccine as well as pfizer
but like with pfizer we've got a
regulator saying it's safe for 12 to 17
year olds but the decision about whether
to actually roll it out to them um that
is based on a recommendation made by a
committee called the jcvi who weighs up
not just safety in the abstract but
other ethical sort of concerns about
giving vaccines to children and so for
example how much direct benefits do
children get from the vaccines how much
is a benefit to society so um there's no
signs yet that this is going to be
extended downwards towards 12 year olds
and i think it will continue to be a
very live debate
okay um and let's look at one other
story then uh katie with you and this is
in the star
nando's clocked by the pandemic now my
kids wanted to go to nando's today and
the doors were closed to sign up we are
temporarily closed because of supply
issues
yeah so that would be one of i think 50
stores affected by this or 50
restaurants
in the nando's chain and they're saying
this is a pin dammit chaos and i think
it goes not so much of it i understand
it's waiting stuff so much as deliveries
and how that's also affecting some pubs
but ultra means no parry chicken so the
paper points out this is good news if
you're a vegetarian or a chicken and
probably worth pointing out and that is
do you have a vegetarian options um but
i think probably the good news here is
uh the pandemic should in theory be
easing quite soon because as monday the
rules change for the double x